okay let's do some audience questions
Raquel wrote in David isn't it a bad
thing when really famous actors are in
movie roles because it's hard to really
see them as the characters because
they're already so well known as people
I prefer movies where the actors are not
well-known because the characters are
more credible you know Raquel I agree
with you I experienced this with the
sci-fi movie that came out a few years
ago now ex machina and at least to me
the actors in that movie were not well
known and it made it a much more
immersive and credible experience and
honestly at the beginning of house of
cards I was having a little bit of a
problem because Kevin Spacey is so well
known that it's hard to see him as Frank
Underwood and not as just Kevin Spacey
with an accent but over time I I did
persevere and get over and really enjoy
house of cards but I completely agree
Pat with with Raquel here I I do enjoy
movies where I don't know any of the
actors because it makes it a much more
realistic experience for me well I just
think it depends on the actor so if
you're talking about you know Brad Pitt
Kate Winslet Meryl Streep they're people
who got the Oscars because they're able
to adapt to so many roles but then there
are those actors who are just the same
person in every movie so like you know
Adam Sandler Michael Cera Will Ferrell
you can't imagine them playing Superman
for example I think it depends well I I
want to say I am NOT a huge fan of Adam
Sandler but in punch-drunk love he did
depart from the standard Adam Sandler
character but by and large yeah I do
agree with you and I used to think
thankless as well Spanglish as well
that's right yeah so there there
actually are and politically I think
that I am completely disgusted by Adam
Sandler but he has actually had a couple
of those roles that are interesting yeah
I guess you're right I mean the best
actors are the best because they are
adapting to these roles but on average
I'm on board
Raquel completely I do tend to enjoy
movies more and I really don't see that
many movies so in particular I like it
when I just show up I don't know
anything about any of the actors and
it's just the story so yes I'm on board
100%